how's it goin Mundy embrose back it's
it's gonna be a mighty great time
together I actually really like this
quiz but this is definitely the hardest
one it's really [ __ ] hard here's the
reason why it's harder I have to spend
like 20 seconds on these if I can just
answer the questions quick it's not a
problem cuz I could just I don't know
mate this is taking too much time you're
not skipping this Sunday I can't skip a
single [ __ ] one sir but I do love the
music in this game is [ __ ] sweet
it's [ __ ] sweet he really improved
them in these [ __ ] Thanks [ __ ] I hate
this one just like holy Shh
that's it any hit job no mainly for fun
ate it up and it's like oh yeah this is
pretty shell and then BAM just bet look
at that look I got over genius huh this
game's gonna give me a heart attack
this is when [ __ ] gets [ __ ] tough
you [ __ ] you will [ __ ] spin
you will spend Oh God I seriously hate
that one so much okay thank you thank
you thank you
all right fight oh no it's Chris it
would like to battle a plum Oh Todd sent
out ion legs poked what the hell is that
oh don't I don't die it's super god
dammit poke yes I hate you you little
ginger bum that's mean what did I ever
do to you
oh I killed your Pokemon what wait I
can't click any of this
what that
ah
what do I know Moyes and delicious but
he's saying its moist and delicious what
is the worst thing you can discover
about your wife she used to be a man
she's your bionic arm oh yeah
isn't that part of that stupid as game I
think I think it's easier biotic hard
yeah it has to be that one yeah
dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever what get away
step adds up I know I don't want to hurt
this girl some kalahari porn is always
the answer
that is some kinky [ __ ] you oh god what
the [ __ ] what has been seen yeah [ __ ]
away
why hasn't there been a question about
Grand Theft Auto yet I'm 12 years old
and what is this I was saving it for
question 95 this one
is it you
- and Jason you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Thais finally that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
bombers a father how do you get off [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you
so we swore we we're real 99 seriously
some of these are so [ __ ] hard nice
house a little bit they fall in there
right no no no poor Jason Jason were hit
by a car
sambar lamps
oh yeah Oh or is it and it's not my
birthday I said your birthday well then
happy birthday mother names cake cake is
a lie of course okay last question brass
can we do incorrect entry will resort in
self-destruction in of this book
hopefully it will blow your hands off
and you will learn a valuable lesson
about taking things I don't belong to
you
and as it was a generous I know five one
thousand nine for question number ninety
[ __ ] I wrote that [ __ ] damn I'll beat
you just give me this
of course of [ __ ] me course so
[ __ ] typical you beat the [ __ ] and it
gives you an F you're like hell yeah but
no oh we did it ice watch this movie
cheers Jinky now XD hey to Beadie
continued spatulas future skip coming
lower than that alright well I guess
we're gonna do chef 3 or 3 I think we
have enough time so chapter 3 is
actually the last one I'm well I'm a
little sad but extremely [ __ ] happy
[ __ ] this game get out impossible Chris
book 3 you might think I'm naked but
things are not always as they seem
chapter 3 let's do it we don't need the
previous story
one fine day Chris the cat was cleaning
his curtain nice picture then when out
of nowhere oh [ __ ]
Chris fought back by shooting it in its
face hey Scott is back back but aliens
kidnapped him for a laugh the aliens
known as plumber Bubba the chicka Chris
took his books and slung him into this
cell baccala the guy in the next cell
had an escape plan involving another
bucket which Chris he is to lock the
cell doors by playing a lot of games
from yeah don't ask
anyway the friendly spatula Norman from
the nextel helped hundreds of flowers
ever called to capture Chris and Nolan
luckily blah blah blah hey well what do
we have here a time machine of course of
course present omen jumped inside the
time machine and match any old buttons
like a pair of idiots this is a bad idea
hopefully you're intelligent enough to
help them get spatula back to the future
what an awesome fun that was an awesome
time what is BC sent for before Chris
bumhole cheese berry shackle
whatever the before Chris all right cool
bird poop and well it has to be this
fabulous lion well then I do must say it
this is said snake Oh
when was the our forum 69 BC dinasaur in
a top hat why yes of course
when was the Ice Age now
no well 2002 [ __ ] logic how may holes in
a trollolol 3 well then for thank you
how do you make diners soul with Lego
[ __ ] well then how the hell do you do
it one burger how do you make a dino
sword your keep it up yes I'll [ __ ] me
at it come on we haven't even gotten
sorry we barely know each other create
the universe oh [ __ ] no
what sure how this crazy universe is no
problem no problem at all bro I got you
I got you bro
I got you you think I don't got you I
[ __ ] got you I told you yeah okay
maybe I don't a bang yeah boy what is
hard is sent for tea and related drinks
in scan throat ticking arcing [ __ ]
digging impossible [ __ ] quiz yeah oh god
Chris well [ __ ] me in the ass it's none
of these are they you [ __ ] [ __ ] guys
of course of course why would it be one
of the answers when it could not be one
of the answers that's great well I click
the bomb
I click the [ __ ] bomb watch which is
a sexiest acusada string Oh the g-string
really I'd like this [ __ ] what do you
call our Nazi hairdresser that Frizer
Hamish guys this hair snip flower girl
on atop a bit Phil what hair snip of
course I'll stroke here you [ __ ] me
what I created a paradox oh god damn it
I hate when I create paradoxes isn't
that right again what the [ __ ] that I
just do which is the coldest I don't
know what polite skin is my Scoble what
polite touch caution age well welcome to
the world of [ __ ] PewDiePie and the
most subscribed [ __ ] but I don't have
any [ __ ] Internet
well I'm gonna go on a limb and say it's
place well that's this quiz budget ran
out the paper apocalypse science [ __ ]
that's what happens now well [ __ ] me
quiz but of their budget ran out okay
what is this that's at it it's a dove
deadlock what happens if you pick the
pickup penguin then we have this
question already
oh come on penguin put blows no yes of
course yes of car what color is
craziness
it's [ __ ] hey girl crazy anus
pink its pledge
I'd say pink because it's fabulous you
can't you just help me Chris I thought
Chris was on my team I would go on the
limb and say that he doesn't have
of course oh [ __ ]
now what do i do what do i whatever
there whatever I would always exploding
fatty technologic Hageman I hide it fly
to fly edition [ __ ] [ __ ] man I'm not
sure if I want to wake that [ __ ] and
are nice hurry up it's the end of the
world we already have this egg questions
I don't remember what what oh no
this isn't a question I just want to
show you some limousine Thanks you know
what thanks appreciate it
appreciate it click the largest click
the [ __ ] logic what are you
doing there
Oh found you [ __ ] see it's the Laureus
in yeah it's tempting to click that
[ __ ] but I'm not gonna do it what
happens if I take away the mouse oh oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] fuel stop
aah what are you
oh damn oh I'm so sorry man I don't come
in my turf again and think there won't
be no repercussions [ __ ] get my tape it
officially massive Katie faked a massive
get a fake everybody a girl all right
what do we got I would say bird a bird
fly penis [ __ ] a birdie [ __ ] well
[ __ ] me about crab killing bird yes of
course
what is the brita code to Jurassic Park
all dinosaurs in a top hat Barney and
[ __ ] [ __ ] me and that's okay 500 plus
teen it's that one isn't it god damn it
it's not EXCI it's yes click the
Mussolini's leaves favorite magazine
well [ __ ] you Mussolini mutts and
flights really are any of these craig
answers no I really have to do this
don't say no don't sing now I click the
question now how do i why wiping them
I'm wiping them out of existence
[ __ ] take this [ __ ] first and then to
stick on this I forget you can do both
of them at the same time with so stupid
that bad breaks
nothing ah [ __ ] you balls why what did
the [ __ ] are you doing shut up shut up
shut up
shy shut up what did I do everywhere was
that garden it was in Pangaea no isn't
that one
what dude had a snippy study at
university but about ism sad and larry
history bacon how does chanel barbarism
who's cutting hair and [ __ ] that's funny
you're a funny man man [ __ ] are you
doing well what the hell what has a
trunk ivory in four legs trunk ivory
four legs
these all are all four things four times
four equals 16 one two three four five
and fourteen fifteen sixteen Mars wasn't
the right answers of course it isn't
that and junk is often true sir rim
sounds often well it has to be the
[ __ ] piano wouldn't he oh my gosh it
I am charging your [ __ ] dick so
[ __ ] hard that I'd have never turn -
[ __ ] dick in my entire [ __ ] period
oh [ __ ] but what why why knowing that no
really that's fine you know lightning
and [ __ ] look at how bright and [ __ ] oh
oh what is that oh I thought it was it
he likes when I rub you don't you no no
please do something
Oh sometimes you just gotta believe he's
got a believe man which age is the best
age the Stone Age the Bronze Age the
Iron Age the Iron Age irony the bond bun
which cheese is made by our God ma what
the [ __ ] it's made oh snap oh my
busting out which one oblate dougela dog
king kelana COFF COFF alone and pink
upon a little adult now it's time to be
happy
oh yeah it's like this one is object by
type for it - oh god [ __ ] me what Oh God
that one right on fire
1 2 3 4 advising that I got [ __ ] me in
there [ __ ] you so [ __ ] hard how do I
know
oh Jesus my guy Ryan who invented the
steam engine
yeah it's game [ __ ] me why just why
oh [ __ ]
why was it tiny what well was it the
labelling sperm labelling spa fabric
labelling is that word diving fabric is
it favorite color has to be read right
oh my god what do I do
what about uh what about out all right
oh it's messing with time dangerous or
agent oh is it messing with time
dangerous the Battle of Hey Oh God
now it's the time where I die KarenT
what do I do now red no is it blue
yellow no blue blue red red comma blue
red blue yellow
oh my god no question to me finish with
it big forever two more questions every
minute with the bed forever girl in
total how many impossible quiz questions
has have there been have 115 this one
there were hundred in I know there 110
in the first 120 the other one I got 370
no 380
what's happening space-time continuum
severely connect dimmers act now
sacrifice your lives
wipe the impossible quiz out of history
oh my god this is 50 [ __ ] 50 well I
guess wipe the impossible quiz out of
history right right which one I don't I
can't hear you
[ __ ] you burn oh my god all the [ __ ]
hours all the tears it's all coming back
to me it's it's all coming what we
[ __ ] did it I salute you bros for
watching this series holy [ __ ]
it's been a lot I probably spent 24
hours in total just playing through all
this yeah it's [ __ ] sad but hey we
did it okay we did it and that's all I
matters I had a lot of fun playing in at
the end of the day this is anyway
whatever like if you enjoyed this
serious and had fun watching I would
appreciate it let me know if what else
you wanted me to see me play and I'll
check it out as always this is for you
bro stay awesome you
you